in this lesson we're going to talk about
writing linear combinations so what is a
linear combination well it's an equation
of a line but instead of in the
slope-intercept form of a line it's in
what's called the standard form of a
line you'll notice that the variables
are on the left and the constant or the
numbers on the right so this is a x plus
b y equals c again sometimes referred to
as standard form
so let's look at an example here see if
you can write an equation and solve this
equation so example number one tells us
that tickets to an amusement park cost
four dollars for children and ten
dollars for adults if 280 dollars was
collected when 20 adults attended how
many children's tickets were sold so see
if you can solve that one on your own
pause the video and we'll go through it
together
so if i was going to write an equation
here let's just say that c is the number
of children's tickets sold
okay so that's four dollars times the
number of children's tickets sold
plus 10 times the number of adult
tickets sold equals a total of 280
dollars collected well they're telling
us that
there were 20 adults so first of all let
me just kind of explain a lot of times
with these linear combinations what
you'll have is you'll have a price
times the quantity so it's like how many
of those you sold how many tickets you
sold times the price per ticket that's
going to give you the total amount and
here same thing again you've got the
cost per ticket times the number of
tickets if you add those together you're
getting the total
okay so that comes up a lot that type of
format there but now here they're
telling us that there were 20 adult
tickets right so 10 times 20 that's 200
so we have 4c plus 200 equals 280.
subtract the 200 from both sides right
so that gives you 80 equals 4c and if
you divide both sides by 4 you can see
that there must have been
20 children's tickets sold so that's how
you would approach these linear
combination type problems
definitely something you want to know
for the act